[Music]
all right thanks everyone coming for
coming to i/o 208 diving into your
billing data with bigquery and data
studio I have the privilege and I'm
really excited that my main job here is
to set the stage for five minutes and
then get out of the way and introduce
you to our customers so they can give
should I spoil it I mean it's a live
demo for basically 45 minutes so if you
all just like say some prayers to
yourself it'll all work out fine I'm
Steven Elliott I'm a product manager on
Google cloud billing and then we have
this is really easy we have Dale like
reliability engineer at VIN dusta and we
have Dale chief technology officer at
VIN dusty round of applause and we'll
introduce min desta a bit more it's a
global b2b company that helps customers
and customers of theirs with marketing
and other tools to help them grow their
businesses so it's a really cool
customer and you'll see kind of what
they do behind the scenes so first to
set the stage I'm gonna go through a
couple of exercises a quick analysis by
hand of the needs for bigquery and
looking at your cloud costs and then I'm
gonna tell you what we're gonna talk
about it and then we're going to talk
about it
so first you know it's it's kind of an
esoteric session title I want to make
sure everyone is in the right place so
quick show of hands how many of you
monitor or managed cloud costs okay so
it's a good start
good you're on the right place how many
of you want or need custom dashboards or
are already building them hey that's
great and then finally how many of you
are satisfied let's sit let's set a high
bar folks fully satisfied by your data
and dashboards today okay all right we
lower the bar a little bit how many of
you are generally satisfied with what
you build today okay Wow okay great
they're in the right place and and I
want to start by Framing this we asked
these key cost managing questions in
every talk that we're giving and I think
these are the nice things about these
questions are there ever
they're fundamental they apply whether
or not you're running in the cloud
running on-premises running a hybrid
solution they apply whether or not
you're running pure infrastructure or
you're doing something really cool with
kubernetes or Ischia so first you know
obviously how much does my app cost
you're building your app you want to
make sure that what it costs is less
than the value it's delivering to you
and you can answer this at many
different levels right you could just
say in general am i spending less than X
per month or you could ask yourself how
much is this VM that's been running for
a long time costing me and is it worth
keeping that thing running the second
question are what are the trends in
those costs so are the cost going up as
expected or are they going up
unexpectedly as the is the trend good or
bad you know growing costs and a bad
thing your cost could grow with customer
demand and if they're growing sub
linearly with customer demand that's
great that's a great growth or it grew
unexpectedly because someone did a
really fancy analysis they didn't need
to on bigquery and they got an answer
that might not have been worth the cost
and then finally what are the cost
drivers so you know what what is it
that's driving the cost do you
understand them do are you able to
delegate cost analysis to the right
people in your organization to
understand the cost at the right level
and that's a lot about what this talk is
going to be about so before we dive in a
little bit further and you'll actually
see a bunch of these when Dale birch
presents we offer several different
tools on Google cloud platform to help
you answer these questions at various
levels of detail so one thing that we
launched recently is billing reports so
at a glance you can see your cost trends
overall and within specific products
within specific SKUs over specific time
ranges so you can kind of drill down
right in the billing UI and see what
your costs are and then we recently
launched and we have a team for this in
in the room forecasting within reports
so you can see forecast based on the
specific configuration of reports you're
looking at to see how the general trend
looks over time we also have budgets and
alerts Matt Leonard who gave a great
talk on this with Lucas Carlson from the
broad yesterday on how to set up budgets
and alerts and receive notifications
about them either via email or
programmatically
via pub/sub so you could set up a cloud
function you could respond to them
automatically and set up very nice
controls in your in your environment and
then finally we have billing exports so
this is where you really want to get
into the fine-grained details of your
bill you want to understand what
resources are running what labels are
attached to those resources you know
whether whether it's the Machine type or
you know which project the big query
analysis took place in a lot of the
detail is in big query export and I can
drive some really nice dashboards that
help your teams understand what's going
on in the cloud so before I turn it over
to Dale just to set the stage about
what's actually going on this shouldn't
be too I guess I'm right in the middle
of the screen let me walk over to the
site so this this shouldn't be
surprising but basically billing starts
with actual usage so on the far left
here we we meter the usage at the
product level and what happens to that
usage is it goes into something I'm
gonna call the pricing engine and I have
some tech leads in here like there is no
such thing that's not what we call it
there's many services way more
complicated than that and like yes but
I'm a product manager so I represent
complexity with a black box so usage
comes into the pricing engine and
there's a bunch of different pricing
schedules that we marry to usage to
produce the cost of your your usage this
should feel right this equation should
not be surprising and then there's
several places where these costs go and
so first of all all the costs go to Dale
not of all cloud customers just of
Dale's costs and that's via the invoice
and then he gets to decide do I like
this invoice do I want to pay this
invoice I'm gonna pay it on time and
generally he has been doing that which
is why he's on stage with me
so the second place that this could go
is cloud billing reports and this is the
way that you can see your costs at a
glance immediately in the billing
console and this is meant to satisfy
many different users so it could be the
chief technology officer it could be the
site reliability engineer it could be
the project owner anyone with billing
privileges can see the costs in their
projects and billing accounts but we're
going to talk about today is the other
place that these do
tell Costco which is into bigquery
billing export if you enable it and then
what you can do with bigquery and that
billing data once you've set it up and
the goal here is really to help you
measure monitor and manage the metrics
that matter the most to you so just keep
that in mind you know you're the three
fundamental questions what are my costs
what are my cost trends where are my
cost drivers and how do I set up the
queries and dashboards that really show
me what I need to know to run my
business
it's about further ado I'll let Dale
Burge take from here
that's all right what one of the deals
so what I wanted to do is I I guess I'd
start off in that we've been a we've
been a Google cloud customer now for
just over eight years and so you'll find
out that's actually before Google cloud
was called Google cloud we started off
on App Engine and App Engine had some
interesting things about billing but for
us we've got a we've got a lot of a
million small businesses that they
currently use our software and we've got
19,000 salespeople that end up using our
platform to deliver those services to
their customers so we do have an
interesting problem in that that that's
actually quite a bit of work to be done
and so Google cloud is has been an
integral part of our strategy in terms
of delivering that and managing the
scale but one of the things that you
often don't hear about the cloud is is
that you know while the cloud does allow
you to avoid availability and
scalability problems of that nature what
it doesn't do is it doesn't eliminate
all scaling problems so one of the
things you'll find is that what you
trade out when you have your own
hardware is when you're when the load
scales instead of you paying with
availability or latency or problems such
as that you end up just paying with cost
and so the important part is is as your
application scales so does your cost and
that can scale in ways that you weren't
a hundred percent ready for and so
watching over your cloud cause is a
really important part like one of the
basics that's really important to how
how you use cloud and so that's why
that's why we've used it in a lot of
different ways and we've used that kind
of from the start and it's gotten a lot
better over the years and specifically
what we found is is that that Google
doesn't miss a lot of things in terms of
your bill it's actually very accurate
the usage is very correct you probably
haven't found out at the end of the
month they forgot to charge you surf or
something and so for us because that
accuracy it's actually a really good
diagnostic tool for us to use so deal
Berkshires gonna walk you through some
of these things and we promise to have a
live demo you guys can actually follow
along and we're gonna build some of the
stuff from the ground up so without that
here you go deal thank you very much
as he said I'm the other Dale from
Vanessa how I got involved with billing
originally was when we first started an
SRE team back in December 2016 Dale came
to us with a problem he showed up in the
room one day and said how are things
going all the things are going pretty
good yes I got this month's Google bill
and it was $20,000 higher than we
expected like that's probably a problem
that's a lot of beer so when you create
a Google bill to being a lot of beer it
doesn't take much to suddenly go from
sixty thousand dollar bill to an eighty
thousand dollar bill all because of a
bug that went in at the start of the
month and nobody noticed and App Engine
just scaled and handled that we had the
additional traffic none of our customers
saw any outages we didn't see any
problems and we just got a big bill so
that was the first post-mortem we held
as an SRE team and we sat down with the
team and we went okay guys how did the
bug get in how did we review it what
were the steps we took in place and how
do we stop this from happening again and
the team went well if we're gonna want a
project we kind of also need to own the
billing for the project we needed to
know what it costs and we need to see
that before you come to us with a
post-mortem booking and saying you guys
spent 20 grand extra what the hell so
that's where I got involved with this we
were trying to come up with some type of
a solution to track our billing in 2016
and there wasn't really anything great
available we looked at crazy things like
scraping the app engine status board to
give you daily totals we figured out the
bigquery export at that point and I sat
down one with one of our data analysts
and said can you teach me how to day to
studio and she kind of laughed and went
well even you can do it so that's how I
ended up in data studio and we've been
using it for dashboards and the
individual team boards ever since so I'm
gonna jump over here in the loop demo
and start at the reports tab and billing
it's important to understand kind of the
scale of and astha here so we've got 96
billable projects within the Google
platform 30 for Google
products that we get billed for and 400
SKUs so it is a little difficult to keep
track of which ones we actually care
about most of the projects aren't
actually costing us a lot of money they
handle small services and most of the
SKUs don't have a large volume on it
there's probably 10 or 12 and every
project that I actually care about and
want to track closely so when I look at
it the dashboard like this I can try and
drill into individual things but I'm
always guessing I'm guessing at what
project is having a problem what area
that project the product it is or what
SKUs within that product are actually
driving it and yes I can find a lot of
information from this dashboard and
their forecasts that they announced
recently we've been using them for a
while and they're pretty killer
I can't match that in data studio but to
actually present this information to a
team is difficult there's not a great I
am story around it I don't want to give
out permissions at the organization
level for it there's no pre-made reports
that they can just hit this and see the
view that they had from last time or
anything like that so while those things
are coming in the meantime we still have
motivation to put effort into building
our own set of dashboards per here so
I'm going to start today by building one
of those dashboards from scratch so what
I'm gonna do is first I'm gonna set up
an export so we've got billing export
here I'm gonna go in and obviously I've
already set this up we've been running
it for a few years now but it's gonna
say which bigquery project I'm gonna
have set up to export to in this case
it's this project and what table set
we're gonna have in there so once this
is saved it's going to going forward
save all your billing data to bigquery
it doesn't do it retro actively but once
you start you can start to build a set
of data that you can use then to analyze
so I'm gonna jump over to bigquery here
and I'm on the data set that I had just
set up to configure it's cloud costs
there's a number of tables in there I'll
explain some of the other ones but the
one we care about is the billing export
v1 so since October of last year when
billing export became GA and everybody
got it the it's version does v1 prior to
that is the couple years of billing data
that we had before with some different
headers and whatnot billing export v1 is
this table set and if I preview this
table you can kind of get a feel for
what we're actually saving to bigquery
here so for every service for every
project
every SKU there's a line item for every
hour of what that was built up with so I
can see I've got compute engine storage
of an image in a project of this project
labels that I've applied to that that
resource so you can split resources by
custom labels and then I get actually
get the cost that it was so the cost and
the currency and the usage amount so
having all this data in bigquery is
going to allow me to actually build
graphs and do analytics over that so how
did we do this before it's probably an
important question I'm sure some others
have spreadsheets like this but we have
these sheets that date back to 2011 and
every month we would get the Google bill
and we would sit there in the
spreadsheet and we type every line item
in for every row and when we saw things
that got screwed up we're like oh no we
got to do something about that so I mean
there's lots of examples in here where
we jump ten thousand dollars a month on
a row item and then three months later
we were down to three thousand dollars a
month on it where we added five grand in
front end instances and it was always a
struggle to actually do anything
proactive with it because we were always
reacting to oh oh big bill how do we
handle this one now so we wasted a lot
of beer on these resources we've we've
made that back significantly by doing
more real-time analysis on it so the
next step once we have an export in data
studio or in bigquery is to actually use
data studio so I'm going to go in data
studio and I'm gonna start a brand new
blank sheet this is for the group here
how many of you are currently using the
billing export okay and how many of you
are actually tying this to data studio
today okay cool Thanks so once we open
up data studio here I'm gonna give it a
new data source it's pretty
straightforward
it's gonna ask me which source I want to
use that'll be bigquery in this
situation I'm gonna find my project and
table name that I set up in the first
place the data set here cost
and I'm gonna choose my v1 export which
is what I configured in my safe so this
is going to connect this bigquery table
to my data studio sheets now the first
thing I'm gonna do is record count I
don't really care about I really want to
do everything by cost so I'm just gonna
disable a record count and say add this
to a report so now I have a blank data
studio report that is connected to all
of my billing data so from here I can do
something like draw a time series graph
to represent what is my cost so I start
a brand new graph it's automatically
gonna figure out that usage start time
is what I'm graphing and I can see my
daily cost in this graph over the last
month for all of my app engine projects
and all of my resources now
from there I probably want to give a
little more value like a scorecard to
say what is the totals for this period
so we're just going to draw a scorecard
here that'll give me my totals for that
time period and it's running its
bigquery queries in the background to
calculate all that information that gets
shown on the screen here it should be
noted you do get billed for the bigquery
queries and for storing the data it's
super minimal I've tried to calculate it
before and we're in single dollars a day
over the last few years that we have
data in there if you were to query
something like logs it's gonna be much
more expensive I've made that mistake
before data students not the right tool
for that so now that I've got a total it
cost on here I probably want to give a
little more control to the user so let's
put a date range selector on again it's
the same thing you just drag on a date
range selector and you can set a default
date range for it I usually do something
along the lines in the last 14 days so
now I have a graph that shows me my
totals for the last 14 days and lets a
user configure that I also want to do
something like give them a filter
options so that the user can choose
which projects they want to do which
projects they want to drill down into
and explore some of their own metrics so
I'm going to put this up here it's
dimension is going to be the project ID
by cost so at this point I have a graph
that lets me choose date ranges shows me
the total for that date range and lets
me pick an individual project
so I could say I just want to see this
one project so I'm looking at a project
now and I've got an anomaly that doesn't
look like the last 14 days how do how do
I actually know is that normal or not
from there we can start to use some of
the tools the data studio provides so if
I look at any graph in here I can put a
compare on that says look at it over the
previous pay period and graph that as
well so now I've got a light blue line
and a dark blue line the light blue line
being what that range was for the last
14 days and the dark blue line being
what we're actually running in this
current time period so now when I view
this graph and grab my project I can
tell is that something that I should
actually care about investigate yes it
probably is because it's an anomaly to
what we expect it to be in that period
so this gives you a really basic I have
a graph now that I can say share it with
a team we can put it on a TV in a room
and represent their one individual
project this brings in all of the
Identity and Access Management of the
Google Docs that you can say here this
person can have it you can share a link
outside the organization and you can
widely distribute those graphs and not
have to be concerned about permissions
or giving access to projects that you
wouldn't want to give otherwise so from
here I'm going to look at some of the
options that you can do outside of
building your own so Google actually has
given a set of templates for visualizing
your time spent in data studio they
wrote this blog post on it and linked
you to an example report if you read
through this blog post it basically
walks you through the same set up
exporting your data looking at your data
and then using this billing report demo
link which opens up this billing report
in data studio that you can clone into
your organization so make a copy of the
report and it's going to ask you to set
up your data sources the instructions
are all in the blog on how to do that
but we're gonna grab a billing export
believe the second one is a spending
trends and the third one is a bigquery
audit source for billing and cloning
that report then gives you something to
with that has all of your data in a
pre-populated dashboard and we don't
heavily leverage this internally because
it's broken down mostly by product by
your big query by your App Engine by
your cloud it cost and we tend to break
things down by project because teams are
responsible for projects not very
individual products across the whole
Google platform but it's a great spot to
actually grab this data this
visualization you can copy graphs out of
it you can look at exactly how they have
designed the graphs and and what data
powers it and grab ideas from there to
kind of populate your own custom
dashboards that would be more useful in
your organization or your type of setup
here so I can basically see by project
my spending by day and overtime in here
so I can jump to projects it's got a
bunch of nice bar graphs and pie graphs
around how we're actually spending money
once it comes up here so well this is a
great source for finding information and
figuring out how to actually build
dashboards within data studio we built
our own from scratch initially to start
with we find that we can get a more
custom view you can tailor something
specific to a team and give that to them
and then they can own that information
so I'm going to jump over another tab
and actually kind of look at what we
have built so we've got 20 pages in this
data studio sheet that are different
reports for different purposes so we've
got a total cost report that breaks down
our cost by environment and shows it
compared to the last two weeks with our
cost and our our credits this is on a TV
in our atrium where every person in the
organization sees it so that anybody
walking by can be empowered to go what
happened there and ask that question we
want to encourage teams to ask that
question because then you kind of take
ownership of the project you can make
those changes to really drive down costs
and manage them over time so from there
we've got individual projects and also
showing the same type of overlay
with with the last periods of time so if
we looked at something like datastore
reads writes in storage we have spikes
every week here and having the context
of what it was over the last period
tells me that those spikes are probably
normal we do bulk work at that point but
if I just saw the spike otherwise I
might spend some time investigating
similar to this Google Cloud endpoints
or service control line item that was a
hundred and fifty dollars higher than
expected that day that's probably worth
me investigating and sure enough there
was a pub sub that was failing and
causing that to retry an additional
traffic but I probably don't want to
actually look at the extra 150 dollars
we spent on datastore reads and writes
in that period because I can see that
they're normal that gives me the context
to look at our data over time I use a
lot of this data as an SRE to see what's
happening in our organization so for
example our cloud sequel cost jumped
here that probably means to me somebody
added a new cloud sequel database or
change to the way it was scaling and if
they haven't talked to me about that I'm
probably concerned about how they set up
security on that cloud sequel database
and what they're actually using that for
maybe that's a dev database that they
pretty
they provisioned with production
resources it's five bucks a day that's
not a huge number but if it can be a
smaller instance type we'll move that
down so generally when I'm looking at
data studio reports there's two
different things I'm looking for either
slow burn things that are eating up cost
over time and just very very slowly
creeping or sudden changes within our
billing data where something spiked and
we're trying to catch it before it it
grows and goes out of control if I look
through some examples that we've had in
the past year or so it talked about the
data store reads matching almost exactly
with the previous the previous period
that's not a concern cloud endpoint
spiking that is more of a concern for me
if I go to something like this graph
this is an external blog that we host
and it also hosts some of our internal
KPIs that get run against bigquery
everyday and say how many reports did we
make how many customers signed in those
types of things and that's a big query
job that happens out of cloud tasks and
in this case February 13th of this year
they
query to bigquery was successful but the
task wasn't completing so the task was
failing and then retrying in the next
hour we were trying collect stats again
it would still call out to bigquery and
fail and retry and we get a graph that
kind of looks like this where over the
course of a weekend in a few days we
went from spending like fifteen dollars
a day on analysis to spending three
hundred twenty-five and having a billing
report in front of a team somebody
looked at it and went oh yeah we should
go fix that because that failing task
isn't just a single failing task it's
actually costing us hundreds of dollars
a day similarly this is the same project
we had just started doing some
development on it and it is one of our
few projects that uses App Engine flex
and you have to spin up your own
machines and spin down your own machines
it doesn't just take care of that when
you when you move traffic around so in
this case they were deploying new
versions and failing to spin down the
old versions so after a few days we
realized that the cost in that project
was climbing we were getting billed for
more Flex instance hours and flex ram
cost and we were expecting to just have
that chat with the team hey you guys are
spending more money than you're
expecting to hear what's going on these
are the lineups that you're using here
we've had we've had lots of examples you
guys probably heard this we had a
development team and what they want to
do is some load testing on a service so
they spun up the biggest possible VM
they can find on GCP they ran all their
tests and then when one of them forgot
to spin it down at the end of the day
and it doesn't take long before you
spend something like that up and all of
a sudden like your test projects you
know it's you're seeing this shark-fin
like this and this is how dale ends up
finding these things and so it's
actually really helpful because a lot of
the stuff that at our office we're
pretty open with permissions on
developers so they can create machines
they can do lots of stuff and this kind
of helps catch those anomalies that it's
like not part of normal operations so
yeah the other one that's super common
is slow burn so where something just
creeps up over time over and over again
and you don't really notice that it's
costing you a whole bunch of money if I
look at a project here which one am I in
our bigquery our bigquery costs for
storage if you look at our long-term
storage cost here in the Green Line
it went up by basically 50 cents a day
and had been climbing for quite a while
and we realized that bad retention
policies happen all the time when you
create a retention policy and bigquery
it's only on newly created tables after
that it doesn't take effect all the old
tables so we had like terabytes of data
hanging around and bigquery that we
really didn't care about but because we
didn't make the buckets with a retention
policy they were just hanging around
forever and ever and we sat down and
well this just keeps increasing we have
to do something about that it's not
increasing in value to the organization
so let's write some scripts actually hit
bigquery and expire all those tables set
expiry times on them and once they
expire the the cost drops back down
again we've seen it in projects where
our cloud storage cost will creep up
over time and next see know we're
spending $30 a day in cloud storage well
we did backups every single night for
multiple years and never cleaned up a
backup because there was just no
retention policy on those buckets
another favorite of mine that we'll find
looking into individual line items is
unused IP addresses you don't pay for
static IPS and Google's infrastructure
unless you don't have them assigned to
something and then you start paying for
them so it's a burden to spend you know
it's not expensive it's five or six
bucks a month but when you have 30 or 40
of them hanging around because somebody
deprovision something it's it adds up
over time and that's beer that we could
be drinking instead of spending it on
static IP addresses we're just not using
so I tend to use our cloud costs as a
set of metrics over what's going on in
my environment newly created items
workloads that I'm not expecting sudden
changes in cost they're usually tied to
something in development teams doing and
gives me that that resource that I can
go talk to the development team and say
hey guys what's going on here and it
also brings that transparency to the
teams that they can own their own cost
they can look at their crafts overtime
they can be responsible for those things
and it kind of pushes that this is their
project not something that we're
administrating and telling them to work
on the permissions thing is also like
it's just huge because you don't want
necessarily want to provide access to
all this billing data to everybody but
you can provide these great views and
and Dale mentioned that you can even do
these things externally so if you want
to share these with somebody else that
the permission wall is just a huge deal
and for everybody in here the the the
sooner you can give people telemetry on
what they're doing I mean you don't even
have to tell developers that they should
be worried about costs if they can
actually see the costs and I mean they
see the shark fin a lot of the time
you're gonna find developers take action
on their own stuff if they know about
this and so in a lot of ways what this
is all about is just bringing that data
to people because in a lot of ways you
know people do a lot of bad things
because they just didn't realize it and
so it basically it's producing more
safety in terms of like when you do
things at the office and you know that
you're gonna see the cost change if you
did something wrong it feels a lot safer
people are going to push more
comfortably and that sort of thing is
really important to us one of the points
I want to also make is with regards to
the wave of the data stored every
project ingest data and billing data and
puts it to bigquery slightly differently
so you'll notice if I look at one of my
production graphs the last day of most
of our App Engine costs all kind of
drop-off here the App Engine doesn't
actually have a point yet for this day
App Engine it's typically about two days
before it ends up in our billing export
so there is a lag time the same leg
times there in the reports so if you're
doing forecasting or something you kind
of have to change your dates back to
being a full set of data that you're not
having that zero point at the end by any
of these graphs I can go and edit and
put a linear regression line across it
within data studio here and say here's
my trend line that's linear and then say
view this report well it's it's always
going to be trending down if I have at
zero data point at the end the guys that
are doing the forecasting have
compensated for that and handle it much
better than we can in data studio with a
simple linear progression so if you have
the opportunity to use the forecasting
tools they are better than what you'll
probably build yourself in here but this
can give you a pretty basic view on what
you need you have been doing over the
course of a month all right well thank
you very much for attending at ten
minutes back
[Music]
you